it's one of the world's most famous
drinking establishments Munich's
hofbrauhaus the huge beer hall can seat
up to 3,500 people and it draws visitors
from around the world all wanting to
sample Bavarian beer and regional
culinary delights it's a very
traditional restaurant and there are
very typical Bavarian dishes like roast
pork knuckles and proper beers I like it
here are new people come along and talk
to us anytime so you meet people from
all over the world some five thousand
liters of hot boy beer are served each
day and to soak it up you can feast on
roasted meats and other authentic
Bavarian specialties including rice for
sausages with sweet mustard and soft
pretzels
and it all started with one man William
v Duke of Bavaria he ordered a brewery
to be built in 1589 to provide the royal
residence with beer more than 200 years
later in 1828 the beer Hall was opened
to the entire public this brewery once
reserved for Bavarian royalty has become
one of music's biggest attractions
drawing more than 1 million visitors a
year they're guaranteed to get a true
taste of Bavarian tradition the regulars
at the hofbrauhaus embodied just that
tradition they each have their own beer
steins locked away this privilege dates
far back in history and there's a long
waiting list
the Munich hofbrauhaus represents
authentic Bavarian traditions which it
exports successfully there are now seven
four four houses in three continents but
you still have to come to Munich if you
want to experience the original
[Music]